my question would just be about kind of
what happens here with fox msnbc cnn etc
what we've seen in my opinion right is
that cable is obviously declining people
are losing ditching their subscriptions
every single year non-paid tv is
increasing are they all just going to
continue to try to transition to these
streaming services like we're seeing
them launch and like what happens there
in your opinion so i've actually i did a
whole monologue on this i predict a
great war against uh your show my show
um and others and here's the reason why
these
streaming services that they're
launching are terrible the cnn one lit
i'm not joking here is some of their
exclusive content is jake tapper's book
club parenting advice with anderson
cooper and fareed zakaria's thoughts on
geopolitics ain't no oh and eva longoria
as well as allison roman's cooking show
ain't nobody gonna pay for that and the
moment that they realize that and they
know that they have poured a hundred
million dollars down the drain same
thing over happening over at peacock
nobody's watching matey haasen's crappy
show or zerlina mac i don't even know
her name honestly sir i think her name
is lena maxwell whatever this is garbage
they are they're pouring millions of
dollars into these terrible products
because they don't actually know how to
program for something that people want
but when they find that out and you guys
know this what are they gonna do they're
gonna use the power that they still have
in the mainstream to try to censor us so
this is gonna happen two to three years
from now um it's really it's gonna be
one of the most brutal wars this is also
why i'm pro bitcoin we have to have the
ability in order to make sure that we're
competing on the level playing field
right now i'm sure you guys see this too
how does cnbc and all these uh places
get all these views on youtube it's not
real it's like a fugazi it's a you know
it's like a ghost view it's something
that gets pumped out into the ecosystem
and given preferential treatment over
our show even though people don't
necessarily want to watch it it's going
to be that times a thousand whenever
they actually have to compete with you
and i when these cable contracts dry up
in a decade from now it's going to be a
blood a bloody civil war
you're obviously building a platform uh
within youtube also within the rss feed
and all the other stuff ancillary to it
but like are you actively thinking about
how to defend yourself against this so
this is the thing my revenue model it
don't youtube revenue is not something
that i even think about and here's why
because mine is direct subscription base
and it's a spy super cast i own the
customer relationship stripe data email
that's it so my business doesn't matter
if we got pulled off of youtube tomorrow
i could still pay my bills i could still
produce a very high quality new show and
i could post it you know wherever i
needed to if if necessary i'm not saying
it's necessarily going to come to that
and i'm not going to lie like it'd still
be a loss in terms of marketing and all
that but it's not existential i built it
from the ground way up with crystal from
day one with that in mind which is we
cannot be reliant on anyone and we
cannot have single points of failure
i've seen this happen too many times
i've seen people program for bs facebook
show some bs show on uh twitter or
whatever and i was like you're out of
your mind they could change their
algorithm like this and you're dead and
they are dead i know people who lost
their livelihoods as a result so that
was my plan my plan was bet on the
actual customer relationship between me
and other people and that was it it's
the purest form of support's purest form
of transaction and ultimately it makes
you uncancelable because they're the
only people who i am ultimately
accountable to